This Aquaman actor had better get his hands
on a shiny leather jacket and a latex jumpsuit
he's going to need 'em for The Matrix 4.
The announcement of a new addition to the
Matrix franchise, directed and co-written
by series originator Lana Wachowski, essentially
blindsided the film world in August 2019.
Even more exciting than the confirmation that
Wachowski was set to helm The Matrix 4 was
news that original stars Carrie-Ann Moss and
Keanu Reeves would return to their iconic
roles as Trinity and Neo.
Little news regarding The Matrix 4 came out
in the time since those announcements, but
now, it appears a new-to-the-franchise face
will join Moss' Trinity and Reeves' Neo in
their fight against the Matrix.
That face belongs to Aquaman star Yahya Abdul-Mateen,
who played the villainous David Kane — better
known as Black Manta — in the Jason Momoa-led
superhero flick.
"Call me…
Black Manta!"
Variety was the first to break the news that
Abdul-Mateen is circling a role in The Matrix
4.
If the outlet's reporting proves accurate,
Abdul-Mateen's role won't merely be as a supporting
player to his iconic co-stars.
Wachowski and The Matrix 4 producers have
reportedly spent some time in recent weeks
meeting with several actors over what's being
called a "secret role" in the upcoming film.
While the exact nature of the character remains
a secret, we know that it's being referred
to as a lead role, and that Abdul-Mateen has
emerged from the recent casting talks as the
frontrunner to land the part.
Though it's unclear who Abdul-Mateen will
play in the The Matrix 4, news of his potential
casting in the film should be met with cheers
from fans of the Matrix franchise and of the
actor himself, who has become one of the brightest
young stars in Hollywood in recent years.
Abdul-Mateen is likely best known for his
turn as Manta in last year's unexpected blockbuster
Aquaman, but he's also delivered more-than-memorable
performances on Baz Luhrmann's musical series
The Get Down, in the Hugh Jackman-led circus
musical The Greatest Showman, and on Hulu's
breakout series The Handmaid's Tale.
"So, are you brave, or… stupid?"
"I'm not brave, so… there you go."
Recently, Abdul-Mateen appeared in Jordan'
Peele's bone-chilling horror confection Us,
and on the "Striking Vipers" episode of Black
Mirror season 5.
He'll next be seen on HBO's Watchmen series,
in Peele's Candyman remake, and as Black Panther
Party co-founder Bobby Seale in Aaron Sorkin's
The Trial of the Chicago 7.
So yeah, if you're not overly familiar with
Yahya Abdul-Mateen's face, you can rest assured
that he'll be bringing some serious cred to
whatever role he plays in Wachowski's new
Matrix film.
Unfortunately, it will probably be quite some
time before we find out who Abdul-Mateen will
play in The Matrix 4, as Wachowski and the
Warner Bros. team will likely want to keep
a very tight lid on plot and character details
which means we really have no idea what's
in store for The Matrix 4, and even less of
a clue how Abdul-Mateen's character will factor
into the action.
Still, it will be interesting to see what
Wachowski does with the new film the first
movie she's directing without the help of
sister Lilly.
Wachowski has enlisted a little help from
her friends in crafting The Matrix 4's secretive
narrative.
Those friends include Cloud Atlas author David
Mitchell and screenwriter Aleksander Hemon,
both of whom contributed work to the Wachowskis'
beloved Netflix series Sense 8.
While we know virtually nothing about what
the trio has done with The Matrix 4's script,
Reeves recently told Entertainment Tonight
that the story is, quote, "very ambitious,
as it should be."
That tease should be more than enough to get
any Matrix fan hyped about what's ahead for
Trinity and Neo and now Abdul-Mateen's mystery
character even if we do have a couple of years
before we find out what will happen in the
film.
The Matrix 4 is scheduled to go before cameras
in 2020, with an undisclosed release date
slated for sometime in 2022.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.